[Music]  it's made red welcome back to bird  Island not much has changed I'm of  course still a hero and this war with  Leonard in the pigs has no end in sight  he is stupid baby  I guess birds and pigs will always be  enemies I know we've had our differences  but we've discovered that there's a  third island in their bodies you destroy  us all  is the scary part we need to put aside  our differences and work together are  you freaking kidding me  each of you has been selected because  you're the best in your field then we  could find we got to be prepared for  anything is what my assistant was going  to say this is the amazing team I've  been working around the clock for  well that's disappointing oh god we  gotta get that key up what's going on  down here  [Music]  yeah I'm just gonna  [Music]